February is American Heart month and
inner mouth and health the sponsors of
this segment want to remind you to
prioritize your heart health we spoke
with a doctor at their Green Valley
Cardiology clinic to learn more
unfortunately we have been in an
epidemic of obesity diabetes both of
which are significant cardiovascular
risk factors
a lot of people don't think they're the
ones that will end up with heart disease
and this may be more notable in females
who often are taking care of everybody
else in their family including their
husbands and they don't realize that
they are just as much at risk for a
heart attack as men do albeit it may be
a little bit later in life but still
something that they really do need to be
aware of one person every 36 seconds
dies from a heart attack
so we all need to get to know our
numbers for prevention so the first
number I would recommend knowing is your
blood pressure 140 over 90 is the upper
cutoff limit but we're really shooting
for a number closer to 120 over 80 as
far as being a normal blood pressure
body mass index is important when your
body mass index is greater than 30 you
certainly are at risk for heart disease
you're usually also at risk for the
development of diabetes people who have
elevated blood sugars are certainly at
risk for diabetes and one of the best
ways we know how outside of dietary
modification is to start and begin a
regular exercise program so the American
Heart Association recommends 150 minutes
of exercise you can break that up any
way you like to 30 minutes five days a
week we also know our patients who have
what we call high waist to hip ratios
meaning you carry most of your adipose
in your abdominal region you're at
higher risk for heart disease another
set of numbers that we would like our
patients to be aware of is their
cholesterol numbers a person's total
cholesterol is the amount of total
cholesterol in the body that is floating
around in the bloodstream and it is
composed of different parts including
HDL cholesterol which is thought to be
protective and LDL cholesterol which is
thought to promote the formation of
plaques in the vessels we do a simple
blood test to measure the total
cholesterol as well as the breakdown of
that the HDL and the LDL I'd like to
provide some tips for remaining heart
healthy try and eat healthy Lee
including lots and lots of fruits and
vegetables more fish and chicken than
beef or pork
try and eat foods that have fiber in
them and use a lot of olive oil and
another big one that has come to light
more recently is getting enough sleep
every night that's very important
thank you Intermountain Health for
sponsoring this segment head to
Intermountain
envy.org Cardiology for more information